[موسيقى]
هو أقرب ما
لدينا منه هو تييري هنري ، ولكن بحلول
الوقت الذي انتقل فيه إلى سالاس
كان في عمر صلاح ، كان قد
انتقل بالفعل إلى مهاجم مركزي
حتى أنه كان يلعب في بعض الأحيان حتى سن 23 عامًا.
غادر تييري هنري ، وأعتقد أن تيري قد
يكون
لاعب كرة القدم الآخر الذي لم يتم تقديره كثيرًا
في تاريخ الدوري الممتاز مع صلاح ،
لذا فقد حصل على أعظم موسم في
تاريخ الدوري الممتاز بشكل واضح في عام 1718 ،
لكنه خلق منذ عام 1718 ، وقد صنع
أكبر عدد من الفرص من قبل أي شخص لا يُدعى
لقد لعب دي بروين
المزيد من التمريرات داخل منطقة الجزاء ،
وخلق المزيد من التمريرات المتوقعة ، والمزيد من
الفرص الكبيرة التي حملت الكرة داخل منطقة
الجزاء ولمسات أكثر من منطقة الجزاء ، لذلك
حمل الكرة واستلم الكرة
في منطقة الجزاء أكثر من أي شخص آخر
وصنع المزيد  بعد اللقطة xg بحيث
تكون قيمة الشيء الذي يحدث
بعد التسديدة حتى يحصل على 0.5 لقطة
وهو أضاف أكثر إلى تلك اللقطة
لأي شخص في الدوري في السنوات الأربع
الماضية على ما
أعتقد  كان يجب أن يفوز في 1718 ، لقد
كان أفضل لاعب على هذا الكوكب في ذلك
العام ، لكن التحذير من ذلك هو أن ميسي
كان أفضل لاعب على هذا الكوكب
لأنه دائمًا أفضل لاعب على هذا
الكوكب حتى لا يتنفس لكنه
كان أفضل لاعب أداء  على هذا
الكوكب في ذلك العام ،
أعتقد أنه إذا استمر في ذلك ،
فلا فائدة من ذلك ، فلا توجد
حجة ، ولا أعتقد أن هناك أي
شخص لديه أي شيء مثل الموسم
الذي يخوضه حاليًا إذا كان ليفربول
يسير بشكل جيد في أوروبا ، فهم
يميلون عمومًا إلى أن يكونوا جيدًا  في الشيء الأوروبي
أعتقد أن لديه الزخم
لك